何？　所沢居なくなってなんでイシツブテずっといるの？と言われるけど。
イシツブテだったの・・・
第一回。　居なさそうな動物の泣き声選手権！
訳わかんない。
ｲや俺も分かんないんですけどね
ちょっと説明してくださいよ
自分が想像して、この世に居なさそうな、動物の鳴き声を発して
笑ったら負け。
頭大丈夫？
解りやすいですよね。
要するに、居なさそうな鳴き声をして、笑ったら勝ち
他の人は変えなきゃいけない訳ね？
そう、そう、そう、そう
見てる皆さんも学校とかで、誰でも簡単にできると思うので是非やってみてください。
最初はグ、じゃんけんぽん。
あいこでしょ！
いっすか？
どぞ！
いきまーす
はい
まあ、まあ、まあ、まあ、、
この世に存在しないんだから、ハリポタの世界に出てきそうな・・・
何でもないです
皆さん、声だけでご想像下さい。
ジュラ紀に居た、こうゆう…恐竜？
ああ、なるほどね？
もう一旦ぐらいやります
ええ、まじで？
一回目だから、まず、
では、私行きます
笑ってんじゃね
ぜんぜん鳴き声じゃないじゃん
違う、違う、違う
工事現場で聞こえた怪鳥？
あの、新種の音がするクラゲ。
設定が一番面白い。設定・・・
ほんとに、たまに海で聞こえるんだって、こういう風に、
じゃ、二回目。これからが本番で。
行きまーす
はい
石を食べるおっきい動物
夜行性の鳥です
夜、これ聞こえるの？
行きます
声が大きいダンゴ虫
えっと、雲の上に居る、あの、三本足の馬。
行きます
これ、何かいやるの？
いや、訳がありまして、鍵盤になってる鳥です。こうやって。
ピアノみたいに。
行きます
行きます。
これは、巣の中で生きてる蟻。
行きます